mark my words what you're about to
witness in my next video is going to
blow your freaking mind for real this
will be without a doubt the best video I
have ever made you're about to witness a
youtuber and an amateur researcher a guy
who studied business and has an
undergrad in communication sociology in
a minor religious studies prove and show
to you with clear evidence proof
pictures that you could see with your
own eyes that there is something far
more mysterious about our ancient past
than from anybody you have ever heard in
the academic world or in documentaries
you are going to see clear evidence and
proof that there was indeed a long lost
ancient global civilization that once
spanned virtually our entire planet for
real this evidence has made my own jaw
drop now this video was gonna supposed
to have been done last Friday or earlier
this week but thanks to partnering with
another youtuber I came across some
great new evidence on Sunday evening so
I'm like okay let me continue to build
this as it changed the narrative of the
video for the better but then last night
I came across something by chance then
made the video that much better but then
this morning yeah I came across
something so good something that so for
real when I say this is gonna make your
jaw drop I realized while looking at it
that my mouth was open
I was mouth breathing while looking at
this because I could not believe well
first of all how much better it made
this video and how much more convincing
of an arguments and made for what I'm
suggesting here but the fact that I've
been researching the topic of lost
ancient civilizations for about 48 more
than four years now closer to five years
and I've never seen a heard of this
before like what so many of the things
that I've come across while building
this video I couldn't believe I had
never seen or heard of before
now some of these things maybe some of
you would have seen before and I'm when
I say some of you I'm talking about
people who have been
following this topic for my channel for
a few years but so many other things
that are included this in this video are
things that it's very unlikely that
you've seen and you'll find yourself
asking why now other people that aren't
as nerds for this awesome topic of
ancient civilizations
oh my their minds are about to be blown
for a rail so yeah I have never been
more excited about a video in my whole
life because it's going to bring up all
kinds of questions evolving what we
thought we knew about our ancient past
regardless of how old you think or how
advanced do you think we work is there's
a lot of debate for that among ancient
history enthusiasts there's all kinds of
bickering back and forth about that but
this will show that without a doubt what
we were taught and is still being taught
in school is so full of holes in so full
of mystery because you're gonna ask
yourselves whoa why haven't I seen or
heard of this before it's that
incredible now I can't take all the
credit in fact so many things I'm not
guys I'm an amateur researcher I'm just
connecting dots and I'm presenting
things in what I consider or hope to be
an engaging fun way a way that gets
people talking and will end in a way
that keeps people's attention spans
going which is no easy task nowadays
right so I have other people to thank
there are other people that have talked
about these subjects some of which that
I've going to be sharing but they
haven't necessarily connected the dots
on everything else and that's where
things start to get really interesting
because the implications of what I'm
about to share are game-changing it's it
proves that our textbooks have to be
rewritten and by the way there's already
enough evidence to suggest that other
professional researchers that have been
studying these topics for decades have
already done an incredible job of doing
that but there's still this massive
resistance among the academic community
the people that write the textbooks the
people who decide what's taught in
school they resist the topic of an
ancient connection among past
civilizations as completely preposterous
they they profusely say that no there is
no ancient
connection nope the Egyptians were the
Egyptians the the cultures of Central
and South America were there but there's
no connection at all but what you're
gonna see in this video is a connection
across the world in countries that you
never realized that these ancient
megalithic sites ever existed and the
similarities are clear as day for all
that have eyes to see is like I said now
great news channel update here so I've
cleared plenty of things off my plate in
my own life now to where I can actually
focus on youtubing full-time all-in and
I've been trying to make that happen for
a while now so the intention going
forward is to make at least one video
every three weeks I mean I would like to
do two videos a month and that's kind of
a goal but that can be hard to pull off
because I want each video I make to be
really good and to do that the amount it
takes time to research and then it takes
time to come up with the creativity of
presenting it in an engaging way and
then digging up photos and connecting
everything and writing up the script and
everything else for the video it all
takes time so every two weeks might not
be doable but if I could do once every
three weeks and that means some months
yeah I would overlap to where I had to
come out in a month that would be
awesome so yeah like mark my words this
will be my best video yet because it's
going because the last several videos
I've made have all been building upon
that yeah there's a lot more to the
story over ancient past and it's a
fascinating mystery and with all the new
technology that we have you know in 2020
we can start digging into more answers
because you know a lot of people don't
realize that most of stuff were taught
in school was based on speculation with
little to no proof many things just
things that were stated or written about
160 plus years ago are much of the same
things that are taught in school today
despite overwhelming scientific evidence
that contradicts it so yeah this is
something that's regardless of what your
personal beliefs are involving our
ancient past one thing we're all gonna
be able to agree on is that whoa there's
way more to the story even people that
stick to their textbooks like a religion
because to be honest many people in the
academics
scientific world it is kind of their
belief system it's just the same part of
the brain as people that are super
religious they all have something in
common which is that when you disagree
with something that they've been
teaching or thought they knew their
whole lives and you say otherwise just
like if you said to someone super
religious or whatever you know they get
upset and this is something we've seen
in the scientific community going back
hundreds of years I mean oh my god look
how they treated Galileo and Copernicus
look how they treated the the Wright
brothers before the flight like a lot of
people that showed up to watch that were
there to watch and die we were calling
them losers and stuff or whatever words
they were calling them because they knew
it was impossible you know so the same
type of mentality exists today humans
haven't changed the ancient philosophers
from thousands of years ago wrote about
the human condition in such an epically
accurate way that it just shows that
nothing has changed and the same thing
exists in the academic world and
scientific world and and this isn't like
to dis it's not to say they're wrong
about everything it's just to simply to
say that when new information comes to
light it's really hard to accept but
we're not about to show you is gonna
make it it's gonna be interesting to see
what people have to say the naysayers
that is so now I have to say that hey
guys yeah this video I really hope to
have it done Friday afternoon but it's
gonna be tight because new there's all
this new information I found the last
few days it's like I just have to
rearrange things and the hardest part
about this video is that even though the
pictures speak for themselves I have to
present it in a way that's engaging
which means that the the order I put the
information in the cadence in which I
deliver it all has to be done just right
in order to make this video as
successful as possible plus I'm still
struggling with the title and thumbnail
might have the title down but it's hard
to figure out a creative thumbnail that
portrays what I'm trying to share
without it looking to click babyish
because on the surface if I say oh yes
there was a long lost ancient global
civilization that once ruled virtually
the entire planet people decide okay mmm
know what I heard about that if that was
true next right even though what I'm
about to show you is gonna prove it so I
have to be very creative on this so yeah
I communicate
on social media that I intended to have
this video done by last Friday or early
this week at the latest and now today's
Wednesday and as soon as I could get
this done is Friday afternoon but that's
tight and I don't like to upload on
weekends because normally the algorithms
favor videos that are uploaded during
the week this is something I've seen in
my own experience as well this is
something that I've read about in depth
while just trying to build my channel
figure out how the algorithm is work so
no I'm not uploading Saturday or Sunday
even though yeah of course there are
videos that are uploaded on weekends
that get millions and millions of views
I rather do Monday instead of Saturday
or Sunday so yeah that's that's planned
for Monday at the latest and this will
be my best video yet guys I've never
been more excited it will definitely get
conversations going and many also think
by the way because I've missed deadlines
before and in trust me when I say that
nobody feels worse or more upset about
that than me it sucks feeling that way
but my intentions have been good
sometimes it's just it's hard you create
a goal for yourself and when you do all
this alone and you keep finding more
information it just keeps pushing things
back and so I don't want to just put
something else or something out in half
asset because I have I have videos from
a couple years ago that have millions of
views that I had no idea we're gonna get
millions of views and I wish I could go
back in time and like change things or
double-check things or make better
arguments but at that time I was just
trying to get better at making videos
talking in front of the camera making
you know provocative thumbnails and
titles that you know to market it to get
people to click right but so that being
said that sometimes you can't rush
creativity so my bad for having missed
deadlines in the past but this will this
will be worth it this this is absolutely
going to be worth the wait
so let me say thank you to everything
thank you to all of my patreon
supporters past and present I mean
there's plenty people who are paid
transports in the past and and aren't
any longer but hey thank you you have
without a doubt made it impact in my
life and my bill
to get to I am now I'm so unbelievably
grateful as well as to all the people
that have signed up to be members of the
Brighton sight channel it's the
community thing you can see it below the
video where it says join I never asked
for it I never brought it up I launched
it and and then a bunch of people came
back to my videos and signed up and I am
so I'm so grateful so all this being
said I'll close this up but our closest
video up and get back to work but yeah
I'm pretty sure you guys are in for
something good here and I just want to
say thanks to everybody and that's
that's shoot from Monday Friday
afternoon at the earliest but Monday
this is same Monday anyways guys I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight thanks for
watching and look forward to that video
and Cheers and love to everybody thanks
for waiting take care